mais nous allons commencer ce journal
par une affaire qui donne des frissons
anne mourgues et pascal stelletta qui
enquêtent depuis plusieurs mois pour
envoyé spécial sont à mesure de nous
révéler un véritable scandale les
membres d'une secte
baptisé les enfants de dieu aurait un
comportement pour le moins pervers à
l'égard d'enfants précisément mauvais
traitements abus sexuels ce soupçon a
incité les gendarmes à intervenir dans
12 villes de france
ils ont fait irruption dans ces étranges
communauté ont retiré de ces sectes 150
enfants et ont placé les parents en
garde à vue les enfants n'ont pas eu
peur n'ont même pas semblé sar o'shea
peut-être était-il préparé depuis
plusieurs mois leurs parents redouter
une action des autorités
les enfants dormaient encore à 6h ce
matin quand les gendarmes
d'aix-en-provence ont investi leur
jardin cerner la maison à l'intérieur
ces gendarmes pensaient trouver dix
enfants ils sont plus de 40
accompagnés de leurs parents tous
membres de la secte des enfants de dieu
depuis plusieurs années les témoignages
s'accumulent contre ce mouvement abus
sexuels sur des enfants
mauvais traitements ce matin cédant 12
communautés simultanément que les
gendarmes sont intervenus
il n'était pas possible sans pénétrer au
sein de ces communautés de s'assurer du
fait que ces pratiques perdurent et
encore dans le voisinage surprise
incrédulité les enfants de dieu étaient
des voisins plutôt tranquille bonjour
bonjour mon champ est survenue une
propre demeure
depuis plusieurs mois les membres de la
secte reconnaissent avoir commis des
erreurs de jeunesse
ils disent aussi avoir changé les
gendarmes disposent de 48 heures de
garde à vue pour prouver le contraire